[Music]
what's going on guys the nominees for
the 2018 Academy Awards were just
recently announced we here at screen
junkies said wait huh we're not sure if
we agree with that
so bunch of us got into a room and we
didn't leave that room until we finished
shooting this video so without further
ado we present the screen junkies Oscar
nominations let's start out with Best
Supporting Actress any Gabriel forget
out that's one scene one scene can't
steal a movie you you nominated in hell
or high water that waitress did I yeah
remember that way George you got one
scene different year they're in for
Mirchi bajji I haven't seen it
you guys gotta sell me on it yes she
genuinely legitimately put out a
fantastic performance in a movie that
was most they kind of ignored by a lot
of people she wanted really blowing me
away okay well you told me I would put
tilde over Holly if I gotta put them
both in the cage until the suite nice
played this fun ridiculous villain that
somehow didn't feel like she does one of
the great things about big sick was the
humanity of it added humanity to the
rom-com Jean yeah oh yes and Holly
Hunter was one of the major catalyst
just Burt and Ray Romano these three my
rage Childers going into the cage I am
so proud to present our nominees for
Best Supporting Actress
Tiffany Haddish girls trip Laurie
Metcalf ladybird allison janney I Tonya
Holly Hunter big sick mary j blige mud
bound so we had three in common with the
actual Academy Award nominees guess you
got those other two wrong huh Academy
next up Best Supporting Actor I'm not
gonna lie this is a super long list and
I hadn't seen maybe one of the movies
and I checked out for a minute six votes
unanimous it goes in two votes or less
first round they're out Jones he was Mac
tonight Jeb Jones's body work was
amazing yes I could do that I'll be back
tonight I knew it just said that we
shouldn't take that nobody saw is it
completely understand but still
evocative performance in which Jamie
Bell not only plays an actor surpass to
me one of the greatest honors Sir
Patrick Stewart has ever received a
screen junkies Oscar nomination yes yes
like right up there with becoming a sir
very key oaken from killing mistake
years Harry killed him so good so base
was just like so perplexing to look at
and he did it with just looking right
tries and again
yeah McKenney moment it's the actual
Best Supporting Actor of favorite
favorite and the snubby Michael Stoler
Rockwell stuhlbarg I'm voting Sam
Rockwell because he carried Iron Man 2
and I don't got no recognition Sam
Rockwell's forgiveness for being a real
piece of crap character came a little
conveniently and too easily that is not
Sam Rock thank you Dad John that's the
way the movie was written his inhabiting
of that role you just bonded a hundred
percent and you were against him when
you thought he for the entire movies
mentor swung me back Rock Mel Spencer
swung me so Rafi was this music Round
Rock well we're back to the store you
know what a back to school bar screen
junkies nominees for Best Supporting
Actor are Willem Dafoe Florida project
Barry kyogen the killing of a sacred
dear Patrick Stewart Logan Ray Romano
the big sick Michael Stuhlbarg call me
by your name we only had one in common
with the Academy and a message to the
young star from killing of a sacred deer
sorry if I butchered your name dude get
ready for more craziness it's Best
Actress Karen from a WWE show
[Music]
I'm gonna yell that sentence for every
argument I wholeheartedly endorse she
absolutely deserved so much more credit
for this film this year this should go
in if we are doing what we should do
here as the screen junkies and get it
right where the Academy got it wrong
this performance goes in last year Joe's
Netflix Molly Shannon performance got in
there no one else had seen and if it's
good enough for Molly shin and I think
it should be good enough for that
bidding you still never saw that movie
and didn't I'm asking you Joe to make
the same leap of faith today that we
made yeah I tell you what oh hold that
thought actually there was a little
mistake Hey so something funny happened
we finished this whole thing and we
realized the Navi plasm wasn't on the
board and we all nominated her would you
say she's at the Hydra parasail oh yeah
so who's going out Brooklyn Prince
sorry Brooklyn Prince this is our own
version of Warren Beatty and Faye
Dunaway Aubrey Plaza you won
here are the screen junkies nominees for
Best Actress Frances McDormand three
billboards outside Epping Missouri
Saoirse Ronan Lady Bird
margot robbie i Tania
Annette Bening film stars don't die in
Liverpool and Aubrey Plaza
Ingrid goes West for this category we
actually had three in common with the
Academy pretty mainstream of us what
would it look like if all the screen
junkies discussed who the Best Actor
nominee should be the front-runner Gary
Oldman for darkest hour what this is a
dark hour for screen jumper Pattinson
for good time you people it's fun it
sounds wrong Vince Vaughn best actor it
is a quiet intensity that erupts in so
much bloodiness
and so much rage and so much contained
passion that I made the most obscene
noises that I've ever made oh he's gonna
most frightening leading roles I've ever
seen one question what were the noises
it made you make again oh sorry buddy
nope you can't reverse my right here
right here all right on principle I
can't vote for circus just because his
performance is crafted and in many cases
altered by an entire team of animators
not taken shape they a screw that well
that depends feel alters yes crafted no
yes no if we're gonna make that argument
that we also have to say that anyone who
was in a movie that was edited by
someone else know anyone's crappy I
haven't had my copyright
and they're facedown in the muscle level
of like being like oh he shouldn't be
smiling that much there's a fundamental
difference between creating the
character in Photoshop or whatever they
use these days and then the screen
junkies nominees for Best Actor are
Robert Pattinson for good time Andy
Serkis war for the Planet of the Apes
Daniel Kalu you forget out kemal
Nanjiani the big sick timothy shallow
may call me by your name this time
around we only had two in common with
the academy they say a movie without a
director is like a restaurant without a
chef you're just sitting at a table
waiting for nothing by the way i just
made that up here's our discussion about
Best Director Jordan Peele yeah yes Toro
che guevara s5 shaun baker the florida
project lee unkrich and Adria Malina for
Coco know - all right Denny Villeneuve
for Blade Runner 2014 I am five PT
Anderson for phantom thread the screen
junkies nominees for Best Director are
Jordan Peele get out
Greta Gerwig Lady Bird Guillermo del
Toro the shape of water Shaun Baker
the florida project Danny Villeneuve
Bladerunner 2049 fYI our list has three
in common with the Academy by the way
I've gotten a lot better at saying Denny
Villeneuve and now the moment you've all
been waiting for
or the moment that's just happening
while you walked away while the video is
still running on your computer this is
our discussion about Best Picture oh and
remember we have five nominees for Best
Picture instead of ten would have gotten
the same reaction water get out any
ghosts West are five votes let's put a
minute call of the day those three in
and call it a day that's lunch
I think Ingrid goes West is one of the
best movies of the year because it is a
movie about issues and Aubrey Plaza's
song it's a total package it's not
everything where it goes to last we're
not just [ __ ] the Academy we're
bucking every other group that gives
award okay can we give out an award for
best trailer that Logan trailer with
[Music]
debate for any one of these movies shape
of water Blade Runner um yeah you know
what I like the I like the fish make a
movie but unfortunately it's always
that's always what's going to be that's
how you background it's not a gay cowboy
movie and no one took it seriously and
that's a mother crash when the Best
Picture Oscar Easter eggs everyone said
that Brokeback Mountain with the gay
cowboy movie that nobody wanted
seriously that's like crash the screen
junkies nominees for Best Picture are
the shape of water ladybird get out the
big sick and Ingrid goes west three of
those are actual Oscar nominees the
other two straight-up snubs what did you
think we left off the list
what film director Best Supporting
Actress Best Actor let us know in the
comments section below who you think got
snubbed by us and the Academy I want to
thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram
bye bye
[Music]